are millennials spoiled babies do
millennials stink
millennials have it too easy millennials
are the absolute cheapest
now five percent still they are ruining
halloween they're the thinnest
generations millennials millennials
millennials
blame it on the millennials
this is the thing about being
progressive and being
woke and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] right
the the young generations the
millennials what you're missing out on
is right that let old people be [ __ ]
old right they'll be dead soon enough
right stop [ __ ] making everyone move
as fast as you're [ __ ] moving
right people are trying right here's the
thing about millennials
you're the worst people that have ever
lived
you're the worst you're just a horrible
breed of people and i don't even blame
you it's just the society you're in
you have social media every single
peanut [ __ ]
thought that ever came into your head oh
[ __ ] comment
what type of [ __ ] low rent [ __ ] are
you
like if you take more than
three selfies a week [ __ ] end it end
it millennials
aren't interested in boobs a no one
cares
and b that is [ __ ]
as a millennial with a lazy eye i'm
looking at boobs
even when i'm not trying
i don't like listen here's the deal
who's under 30.
well now i feel weird about this job
i had no idea no let me let me tell you
this i don't i i get angry at
millennials
because i do it not not the old thank
you
thank thank you the four old people here
just three elderly people in the back
who work security for this theater god
bless you
[ __ ] these kids
no here's the deal if you're under 23
you have a fake job
that's listen unless you're in the
military or a nurse and you're not
if you're under 23 you have a fake job
but the problem is
if you ask a millennial about their fake
job
they are so confident that you feel like
a piece of [ __ ]
you're like what do you do for a living
they're like actually i'm an instagram
filter
[Applause]
excuse me yeah i'm valencia
i had no idea
i had a real job when i was a millennial
okay i didn't do any of this [ __ ]
like manage the instagram account of a
tweet or whatever the hell you do
okay i had a real job i sold subprime
mortgages thank you very much
thank you i sold mansions to janitors
and they loved it for six to eight
months and then
i had to stop doing that because i was
growing as a person and the fbi and all
this [ __ ]
and i was evolving and i moved from long
island to new york city and i had to get
another sales job
and this is how soft new york city is i
don't want it to happen in new orleans
i see it happening by the way i don't
want it to happen this is how soft
new york is the only thing
that i could interview to sell was
organic
baby food
but the problem was i brought all of the
aggression from the mortgage world into
that interview
it was just an old hipster he's like hey
welcome to happy baby
i was like i will do whatever the [ __ ]
needs to be done
he's like whoa we're just really proud
of the ingredients we put in the jars
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] what goes
in those jars i work for you
he's like well this is just going to the
food co-op and talking to parents i'm
like well i won't talk to the feds
put me in this radish pudding game now
they called the cops but [ __ ] them
they don't want to make money this is
from tara
everyone needs to lay the [ __ ] off of
millennials because it's factually
proven
that we are more [ __ ] than any
previous generation
now tara what i like is the courage to
just make [ __ ] up
i would say being born during the great
depression
not a day at the beach
i would say world war one was no fun
anybody born during the black plague
would have a tendency to disagree with
you
okay i mean these are it's shitty uh for
sure but
not uh not [ __ ] more than any previous
generation
i can go through all of them if you like
you're more [ __ ] than any
debt wise environmentally politically
yeah yeah
are you [ __ ] in in [ __ ]
pittsburgh
literally until the steel industry kind
of went belly up
people would walk right [ __ ] just came
down on them every day
they were covered in soot every day so
no no no no no
it's shitty
[Music]
what's shitty is that the people in
charge don't know anything about the
environment
and think that toxic things are fun
that's [ __ ] up
but there were shittier times when
people didn't even know
they just go oh look it's it's black
shit's falling on us
debt wise environmentally politically
and it was our parents and their parents
who [ __ ] us
and their parents before them and then
their parents before them everybody's
[ __ ] everybody
that you can look at the history of
mankind as one
one generation [ __ ] every generation
is [ __ ] it's a big
circle of [ __ ] ups
okay i mean seriously that's what it is
and i'm sorry and i've i've talked about
it you can go watch my [ __ ] i'd say i
blame my generation
about eight ten years ago when the
special i did
i went on for 15 minutes about how we
[ __ ] [ __ ] all over everything
so don't yell at me god damn it
um
no it's uh and now they want to blame us
i don't
they they they don't want to blame you
they're just irritated
they just go what are they doing it's
they're just crazy they're on their
phones all the time
that's what they get upset with nobody's
blaming you
nobody they don't even know nobody's
blaming you because they don't blame
anybody for anything anymore
i'm the only one who [ __ ] seems to
blame things and then the people seem to
come see me because wow
who i can't believe he's blaming [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] them [ __ ] everyone who
doesn't understand how economics
actually [ __ ] works
well uh i can guarantee you that the
pendulum is going to swing
back and then you'll go [ __ ]
it was so much nicer when i was
irritated
one way out of this tara it was
something i've gotten
something recently one way you break
this kind of cycle of
dealing with the nonsense find something
you really love to do
and focus on it and [ __ ] everything else
and it will change the way you look at
everything
just refine that once you find that none
of this [ __ ] will bother you
okay you'll be literally
you know you'll go you'll go and you'll
come back
from doing what it is you love and then
you'll try to get some water and
it'll be mud but you go son of a [ __ ]
at least i'm happy
[Music]
[Music]
how i hope and pray normally i wouldn't
sing in public but i feel like i'm in my
bedroom i have plush furniture like this
in my bedroom
look at that one with the [ __ ]
overhang sorry did this go out again
sorry sorry i'm sorry to each and every
one of you especially the millennials
i'm sure you [ __ ] heard about it and
you're gonna hashtag some sort of me too
me too i couldn't hear either me too
me too i also had something bad happen
hey here's something you can say in this
country three [ __ ] meals a day
me too me too first world country me too
flat screen tv me too
everybody dwelling on the negative he's
[ __ ] feminist man i swear to god i
want to go to one of their events
and just get up to that microphone and
just be like excuse me
is there anything good about being a
woman
at any point during your day are you
like thank god i'm a woman
or i would have had to step in that
muddy that mud puddle whatever the [ __ ]
i'm supposed to do i'm supposed to take
my [ __ ] coat off
you know a little more respect for these
feminists when they care a little bit
more about guys jackets
you know it's always a [ __ ] issue
that they care about
you know and in the 70s we were forced
to wear clogs
and a lot of our mothers blew out their
acls
gives a [ __ ]
i'll listen to a feminist but not if
she's white you know what i mean it's
like
you know i won't okay at the end of the
day you were a white woman in the united
states of america what is the problem
huh did someone take away your rose for
the afternoon
did they shut down the [ __ ] trolley
down at the mall
what what is happening in your world no
seriously all right look if you're
living some honey boo boo lifestyle
right you're living off the appalachian
somebody got rickets and lyme disease
right
husband never wear a shirt you know what
i mean
[Laughter]
he just wears that long underwear with
the trap drawer
behind the back you know what i mean you
know he's going out when he puts on his
best overalls
right those guys have it right those
guys know how to live out there
if you truly want to get along with the
woman you got to live on right off the
appalachian trail
you know you got to be off the grid and
you just have to have no television okay
and then you can slap her around all you
want and she's never going to know
this is just how it is
you know what i mean if you have a dirt
floor like taking a beating is not the
big it just seems like part of your life
it's like seamless
the worst thing you could we ever did
for women is linoleum
and like wall-to-wall carpet then we
lost all of our power
yeah you've seen it when twitter first
came out women were just hashtagging
whatever you say
and
[Laughter]
now somebody's going to take a snippet
of that and put it on a [ __ ] news
show
and then i'm going to get in trouble are
you trying to say that women
deserve to be beaten on dirt floors and
at that point you just got to go with it
just be like yes
and i'm running for president in [ __ ]
2020.